along with the holidays comes a lot of
celebration and that usually involves
food and drinks so how do we stay
healthy without depriving ourselves
wellness by kelly owner kelly namiro is
here to show us how welcome back thank
you thank you so much for having me okay
so tell us what can we do where we feel
like we're indulging a little bit but we
also get the health benefits 100 and i
think it's so important during this time
of year where there's so much sugar
around to set ourselves up for success
in the beginning of the day to balance
our blood sugar make sure that we when
we do that we're really not gonna have
those sugar cravings as much as we would
generally so having breakfast not
skipping it super important and we can
do that with a mint chip smoothie okay
so i i know a lot of people do skip
breakfast yeah a lot of people do the
intermittent fasting you're saying this
is this is not good no because then you
end up more hungry especially if you're
not having carbs which are like is like
the glucose that's what feeds your cells
gives you energy keeps your mood stable
throughout the day we really want you to
be having breakfast to set yourself up
for that success that you don't have
that blood sugar crash and you feel like
oh i am listening to you on that because
i usually skip breakfast but a smoothie
a mint chip smoothie sounds amazing so
what do we have here so we have banana i
would say if you're at home use a frozen
banana that's gonna make your smoothie
nice and thick and creamy you can also
add like frozen cauliflower i know that
sounds weird but you do not taste it
really
it's super delicious and it makes it
nice and thick and adds a lot more fiber
okay so from there we're going to add
some spinach which greens super
important tons of antioxidants again
more fiber to help keep digestion
regular and just about a handful of it
just kind of throw it in yeah i would
say a cup cup and a half we do not as
americans eat enough vegetables yes so
that's super important then i do a
quarter to a half cup of fresh mint i
actually picked this from my garden um
which is super fun that's actually and
it makes you feel like hey i'm doing i'm
using my own stuff like i'm saving money
right good okay and mint is really great
for digestion it's great for if you do
feel like nauseous or anything like that
it's really good for the digestive
system so i love that extra benefit
coconut oil is a good healthy fat we
want to make sure that breakfast has
protein fat a good healthy carb which is
from the banana and fiber from the
spinach this is cacao nibs this is great
for boosting your energy lots of
tons of energy can come from cacao
there's a little bit of caffeine but
tons of antioxidants but you feel like
you're getting that little treat yeah
like the chocolate this is so good okay
and then protein powder i use a vanilla
protein powder but if you have chocolate
if you want to use a chocolate protein
powder at home that's great okay and
then we add in a plant-based nut milk
and we blend it up all right so let's
see what all of this put together turns
into this is the mint chip smoothie we
got the blender here okay i'm gonna get
a glass and then we're going to give it
a shot now
you were talking about some like hormone
imbalances this can really affect if you
don't uh eat properly you can affect
your insulin your blood sugar and that's
what causes you to end up gaining weight
in the long term so some people might
see intermittent fasting give them those
results in the short term but you end up
gaining weight in the long run okay
let's blend here we go check it
out
i love our kitchen i like we're like
checking drawers like what do we got
here
all right it looks minty it looks
chocolatey
all right okay
let's see
from someone who doesn't eat breakfast
to someone who's gonna say i know it
does not look like
the most delicious but but how's it
taste let's see let me know all right
um
seriously like mint chip ice cream right
kelly this is so good how is there
spinach and
this is so good my gosh
i'm going to start making this for
breakfast that's it there we go it's
settled
thank you so much how do people get in
touch with you you can find me at
wellnessbykelly.com i also have an app
where i share all of my recipes
including this one workouts and
meditations so that you can live your
most